aoc was just on don lemon's show on cnn
and aoc said it's very important not
just to fact
check republicans but to confront their
core logic so congresswoman i want to
ask you about this debate that we're
seeing over critical race theory do you
think republican efforts to redefine it
and use it as a scare tactic do you
think it's working
well i do think it's working because
what we have seen
is that the republican-based republican
party has really pivoted to a strategy
of using race and using just the
changing demographics of this country
and as we saw on january 6 using a white
supremacist
core logic in order to reanimate a very
core fear in this country of the other
and so what's really important is that
we come together and have a very strong
rebuttal
to that core logic not just in fact
checking republican claims
but actually confronting the core logic
and addressing the core fears that they
are trying to really tap into when they
try to use
terms like critical race theory as a
proxy for just saying
talking about race in schools in general
so she makes
actually a good point she makes a bunch
of stupid points but she makes
a good point here it's it's also worth
noting i don't want to let this
get away the left always tells us that
if you believe that there is an
intentional effort
to change the demographics of this
country that it's a conspiracy theory
and it's white supremacist and it's
crazy and yet aoc is admitting it here
she's saying that yes there is an effort
underway to change the demographics of
this country we're doing it and if you
complain about it you're a white
supremacist too
so if you think it's a it's real you're
a white supremacist
if we then tell you it's real and you
object in any way your white
supremacists just wanted to point that
out but what she says here is it's not
enough to fact
check republicans because you have to
confront their core logic and she just
keeps saying core lot whatever that
means
logic is logic it's not it's not your
logic and my logic and his logic there
is logic
right and we use logic to make arguments
to one another
so when you fact check you are checking
the person's logic the logical
progressions that they have made
and you can also check their premises
and you can
okay fine what aoc is
observing though is she can't fact check
the republicans because on the on the
facts republicans are right
generally speaking on on whatever the
issue of the day is
okay generally speaking the republicans
are more likely to be right than the
democrats
so she said remember when she said well
i'm not factually right but i'm morally
right
not factually correct but i'm morally
right so you're saying yeah we can't
check their facts but we can
confront their core logic meaning logic
itself the whole point of these
of these new leftist theories is we're
going to argue against
logic there is no objective truth there
is no faculty of reason
the phrase objective truth itself is a
white supremacist dog whistle
and so we've got to confront that that
is what not just critical race theory
but
post-modernism so deconstruction so many
of these
of these leftist arguments are about
imposing one's tyranny of will absent
any kind of logical argument that's an
offer you can't refuse because they're
going to make it with their fist
hey i'm glad you like that clip
seriously i'm very glad that
pleases me greatly i would be even
happier if you would watch the whole
show
it is called an offer you can't refuse
go check it out it's here on youtube
it's on apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play myspace xanga live journal
hotmail
linux i don't know it's everywhere go
get it subscribe and by the way you can
still order
my number one national bestselling book
speechless controlling words controlling
mine see you next time
you